he is the former mayor of Tallahassee
Florida and the 2018 Democratic nominee
for governor of Florida came this close
Andrew Gilliam is over here
[Applause]
all right so Andrew now the Democrats
are looking for a candidate there's only
a hundred and eight in the fields Jimmy
Carter is a saw John Edwards is thinking
about it so no but it's interesting that
you've narrowly lost your race so did
Stacy a dream so did better O'Rourke and
it's no longer a deal breaker to have
lost to go on to run for president I
mean I agree with it first of all
history teaches us that right Lincoln
loss went on to become president but I
wouldn't underestimate what was done
even though beto and Stacy and myself
weren't a but across the finish line as
the governor's necessarily we both saw
supercharged turnout in Florida and
Georgia and Texas Stacy juiced as many
Democrats as she could out of the state
of Georgia and you also had the guy who
was the referee yeah also being the
player on the field
right next time you mean Florida is
gonna be a different ball game because
they passed the amendment for right
that's right ex-felons can vote that's
right that's right that's right I don't
make a big difference that's right
one point for one point four million
people and now Florida was one of the
final few states that still had the Jim
Crow era policy that once you committed
a felony you would have you a right to
vote permanently taken away I don't know
about you but I don't want to be judged
forever by my worst day and luckily
Florida voters restoring rights and
for some he could be vote I I sold
marijuana back when it was illegal
that's true
oh you know it's true okay and actually
some of the pot came from Florida so 60%
of the American electorate one's
marijuana to be legal 85 percent of
people under 35 how much political cover
does your party need to just go okay
let's make this [ __ ] legal look I read I
ran as the governor of Florida for the
governor of Florida advocating for
legalization of marijuana I know I don't
have to be convinced on this I also know
that the Florida Legislature even under
Republicans shared leadership this week
decided that you can do smokeable
marijuana for for medical purposes so
we're making progress mate we're making
progress and we're gonna okay so Nancy
Pelosi this week I'll read her statement
on impeachment unless there's something
so compelling and overwhelmingly and
bipartisan I don't think we should go
down that path now let's break that down
compelling it certainly is compelling
overwhelming definitely overwhelming
it's just not bipartisan I must tell you
I've been for impeachment but Nancy
Pelosi knows a thing or two yeah we got
to get that issue right yeah so when
beto announced this week they said well
he flip-flop he said we should impeach
and now he doesn't know yeah we got to
think this through
that's not flip-flopping let's get this
one right where you stand well I mean
Iran also on impeaching the president I
think Donald Trump is uniquely
unqualified for the holds
I think the the president has broken the
law began on me I'm not sure when it
began but we know for sure that he fired
the FBI director because well he
wouldn't interfere we also know for sure
that he wouldn't be convicted so it
would just be doing it listen all I
would say is that you're elected to
Congress you're elected to the United
States Senate to do your job yeah all I
want as a voter is for them to do their
jobs okay what do you think about this
question that all the Democrats are
being asked now are you a socialist or
are you a Joe Scarborough asked John
Hickenlooper he would be one of your
competition if you got in the race he
said would you call yourself a proud
capitalist and Hickenlooper said oh I
don't know the labels I'm not sure any
of them fit is that hard to answer for
you or you I am a capitalist you have
also conscious that the rules of the
playing field are not leveled right now
when you hear the kind of wealth
disparities that exists in this country
when you see small businesses in
communities all across the country being
snuffed out quite frankly because of the
the rules not being leveled for them
there's something wrong with that and I
think Americans know this Donald Trump's
biggest fear is that we're gonna
recognize those of us who were in the
working class of this country that we
actually got a lot more in common than
we have a part and that he actually is
doing the bidding of the top one percent
and not the rest of us the candidate on
the Democratic side who goes out and
makes the case for working people around
why it is they ought to believe in our
party again I think will be the one who
wins and that's not a racial comment
when I say well people
I'm a working folks I get up every
single day to make a living for
themselves and their families need to
know that we have their backs first and
foremost they certainly
we certainly have elements of socialism
in our system as do all modern
democracies but the system itself you
can't be afraid I think if the Democrats
were afraid to say I'm a capitalist
first of all the jury's in we had this
debate in the twentieth century
capitalism with all its flaws and it
does need regulation absolutely it's
still better than the government owning
the means of production we had this but
I don't I don't know anybody right now
and including Bernie who is saying that
the government ought to take no no right
all and look people of economic and
otherwise people here socialism and
that's that's what well guess what you
can be the most conservative Democrat
running in this race for president and
the Republicans are still going to call
you a socialist that's the that is our
game plan and so what I would suggest
what I would suggest is instead of being
afraid of those labels that our
candidates run as who they are what do
you believe what do you stand for what
are you gonna do for everyday working
folks my mother was a school bus driver
my dad was a construction worker he just
passed a week uh almost a week or so ago
these are folks who's gotta every single
day doing everything that they could to
make away from me of my six siblings
they kept a roof over our head food on
the table clothes on our backs we need
to talk to those individuals around what
we're gonna do to make their lives
better okay
you